hello everyone i'm samantha harris and
welcome to culinary
genius our crack team of contestants are
ready and waiting to do
culinary battle now they've each got a
lucky item from their kitchen at home
and
they're really hoping that it will help
them gordon ramsay will be giving advice
on today's main
ingredient but first overseeing this
battle it's chef
edward lee
how you doing good what are you
expecting from our contestants today
today
we have a challenge that is going to
test both your endurance
as well as your cooking skills for the
three survivors
i have chosen a seasonal pantry of
italian
mexican chinese and greek ingredients
thank you very much edward now in round
one our contestants will play a race to
the finish line
culinary challenge the two cooks who
come last
will have to hang up their culinary
genius aprons and leave the competition
so let's reveal what's in store for
round one
contestants please lift your cloches
it's eggs now before edward explains the
first challenge
let's hear from our mega chef gordon
ramsay
right guys today you get to work with
these incredible fresh eggs
here's a fact america produces 90
billion
eggs a year can you imagine life with no
eggs no
cakes no pasta no mooses no hollandaise
sauce
what would i do with these today i'd
turn them into the most amazing
delicious
rich scrambled egg and the secret behind
any scrambled egg
is to season at the end not the
beginning if you season at the beginning
it turns the eggs gray so edward what's
our first challenge today
thanks gordon today cooks you must
separate six eggs
and beat the egg whites into stiff peaks
as quickly as possible
this is a speed test as well first crack
the egg
crack it open it right up into your
fingers
eggshells go in here you want to sort of
drip the egg whites through your fingers
press firmly all the egg white drops egg
yolks go in here
got it and then the egg white goes into
your master bowl
i always crack my egg against a flat
hard surface
because it creates a nice even
crack don't bang the egg against the
hard surface just a gentle crack if you
get any yolk
or shell in the egg whites you're gonna
have to start over again
okay remember this is a time test so the
faster you can get your egg whites in
the bowl the sooner you can get started
whisking
put your bowl on top of the towel so you
have a nice firm surface
start out with small
very firm very constant
rotations try to get a rhythm going as
you get going you go a little faster a
little faster
the egg whites will start to firm up now
you can see it's completely opaque
we're almost there okay now these
are soft peaks because when i lift it up
it kind of curls right still not ready
ah there we are when you flip it over
it should stay firm when you're finished
ring your bell
samantha and i will come by and test
your egg whites you are going to have to
lift that bowl above your head
got it cooks all right let's get back to
your stations let's do this
thank you all right well our cooks are
ready to whip
through this challenge the first three
cooks to finish will go through to round
two let the battle begin
i know i make a lot of egg white omelets
myself but there are no
so many other uses for egg whites what
are they so classic french cuisine
you cannot make souffles without egg
whites
can't make mooses without egg whites
there's so many things anytime you need
a light
fluffy texture egg whites go right in
there
[Music]
leanne how you doing uh doing all right
this isn't usually a method that i would
use
how would you do it i would typically
tip the yolk
back and forth between the shells i know
you got to go faster you know what i
already hear somebody
whispering here's some whiskey hurry up
i'm putting your that's the photo of my
grandmother really
yep and my grandmother's the one who
taught me everything i know about
cooking i love grandma's but yeah you
could have brought something a little
more practical i think she'll help me
though i think uh
she's got it so we're going let's go
kyle no pressure but other people have
been whipping for a little bit of time
are you feeling like you're losing time
here probably yeah
just a little bit was this a challenge
yeah i'm used to doing it a little bit
differently just
uh back and forth between the eggs keep
it up
jim you were the first ones to get your
egg whites whisking
how's that feel this was pretty good
what'd you bring from home
i brought some persian spice oh really
yeah
what do you think wow that's nice hey
listen keep focused on that keep going
hi leslie do you have a special marinade
from home that you have to do
it's got a combination of urine sake and
miso paste with a little bit of maple
syrup and
um tamarind oh so anything that will be
nice for
the next course if we get through well
good luck thank you
jt what in the world are you doing i
don't know okay
this is not play time this is serious
get in there get angry come on let me do
that arm faster faster faster faster go
[Applause]
that is a pass let's see who's uh all
right come on there are two more places
in the finals
two more come on i'm going as quick as i
can chef
is it burning are your arms broken you
feel a little bit um
all right okay how do you feel let's see
all right let's try it i think you're
gonna do it do it do it do it do it do
it
that's a pass keep going keep going all
right kyle let's see
are you gonna have the third place let's
see let's go one two three you got it
third place all right style is true all
right well congratulations to jim
kyle you are through to the final you
know sadly of course that means that we
have to say goodbye to jt
and leanne but thank you so much for
your fine efforts today join us after
the break when our three remaining
contestants must turn their eggs into a
winning dish worthy of a culinary genius
welcome back our three remaining cooks
have literally
beaten the competition now all that
stands between our contestants and a
thousand dollars
is the final cook-off so edward what are
you looking for
from our three finalists all right today
your challenge
is eggs so i want to see eggs front and
center on that plate i don't want to see
a garnish of eggs
i really want to see the egg cooked
perfectly and then think about how
all the other flavors are going to
complement that egg
i put a lot of extra proteins in there
so your dish can go vegetarian
it can go fish it can go meat just make
it one
beautiful looking dish on that plate and
now it is time to
stock up on ingredients from our pantry
and you're just gonna have
two minutes also check out the fridge
your time starts
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
edward tell us what's in the pantry
we've got ingredients from all over the
globe right
so we've got eggplant we have thai basil
we've got american bacon
haddock chicken breast there's truffles
in there there's so many things in the
pantry to choose from
and then of course in the fridge there's
feta parmesan gruyere cheeses there's
also
fresh pasta sheets i can't wait to see
what they come up with
just one minute left halfway through so
one minute left
jim is just attacking that pantry what's
going through my mind is
that i need to get this done quickly i
need to be succinct
with the recipe now you only get two
minutes in the pantry however you can go
back to the fridge if you need to
things that caught my eye some greens
some mushroom a little bit of chili for
color
and i took probably more things than i
thought i would actually use
ten nine eight seven
six five four three
two one
now you have 25 minutes to prepare cook
and ultimately plate a dish
let the final battle begin
hey there jim you're really grabbing
lots of good stuff here where did you
grab it specifically
uh i'm making pasta dish so i'm making a
pasta veletta which is
pasta with macaroni some assorted herbs
cream sauce with the curry
put a couple eggs on top what's your uh
cooking experience come from my cooking
experience comes from cooking
for my wife your wife is in the audience
today right she is where are you wave
out to us hey laura hi laura how you
doing
and then what's your favorite dish that
you cook for her this is one of them
you've got a very simple pantry make
sure everything's cooked perfectly okay
good luck have fun with it thanks
hi there kyle how you doing making me a
taco
making you some eggs benedict on
tortilla nice
i have a really great ingredient that
goes well with eggs so i think i've got
that
locked down basically the main spice for
the uh eggs better dip yeah you're
making a very simple dish remember when
you make a simple dish
i'm gonna notice everything on that
plate okay so just make sure it's
perfect all right
lastly i see a couple proteins here you
got some fish some chicken
i'm gonna make some fish that i'm gonna
use
uh egg and flour to bread and quickly
pan fry and try and make up some tacos
and i'm gonna make a kind of asian rice
gonna have a nice fried egg on top
just sort of like a nasty goring
inspired so leslie
are you cooking me a three-course meal
here because i only need one dish from
you
yes but it's gonna have yeah it's gonna
have all of this
and the rice and the tacos and the
veggies yeah and that in there yeah okay
tell me what's in your marinade it's
delicious thank you so the marinade is
miran
sake miso tiny bit of tamarind
and a tiny bit of maple syrup are you
trying to go to market with this is this
gonna be
leslie's new secret super sauce that is
my secret marinade i might have to
invest in your company it's
delicious good great all right you've
got a lot of ingredients here you've got
some competing flavors
remember eggs just a challenge bring it
all together give me one unified dish
okay good luck thanks
jim is making a pasta valetta
with this beautiful curried cream sauce
it's a very simple dish
i have to see how that persian spice
is going to incorporate into basically
an italian dish we'll see if that was a
mistake
all right so you know kyle here is
making this egg benedict on tortillas
uh you said it was very simple when you
went over there you're a little
concerned with the simplicity of it
um i just don't want it to seem like a
simple brunch dish this is culinary
genius
i hope he does something with that dish
that kind of elevates it a little bit
for leslie are you concerned that she's
trying to take on too much i'm actually
a lot concerned
there's a lot going on on that table
there's a lot of flavors there that kind
of
are competing it takes a really delicate
touch to put those together
genius and she has this marinade as well
that she brought in how is that gonna
work with it though god the marinade is
delicious
all these beautiful options in the
pantry all the different proteins what
would you have chosen to make
really simply cooked pasta maybe you
know cut wide like fettuccine okay
delicate cream sauce poached egg
truffles on top
a little parmesan little fresh herbs on
top and you're done easy with a little
buster
i would eat that okay cooks we are at
the halfway point
this is one tremendous battle and it's
only going to get
more intense as the clock ticks down
join us after the break for the big
finish welcome back
our three finalists have one eye on the
clock and one eye
on their eggs as they attempt to win
culinary genius
all right kyle why do you want to win
the title of culinary genius i'm just a
bit of a perfectionist i guess
okay and who do you like cooking for the
most my girlfriend i have to say
at least you'll try this stuff when i
get very adventurous right yeah it's
pretty special
what is his best dish that you love
eating egg benedict
so eggs are his forte then in your mind
well good luck kyle
continue on thanks cook's worth the
eight minute mark eight minutes
jim you're you're stirring up a good
smell here what do you usually tend to
cook at home
i cook a lot of mexican food oh really
what would it mean to you to win
culinary genius oh it would be fabulous
a kind of validation of what i like to
do which is cook
well we look forward to seeing how your
dish turns out good luck
lastly you seem to have things under
control here um
my nasty going rice going i've done my
fish and i'm just gonna like
make the tacos look nice and toasty
you're a very calm
cook now i know you're a psychotherapist
is this sort of your zen it is actually
really
quite therapeutic in a way just i would
think to cook and chop and
yeah do those things good luck thank you
okay
kyle what's going on how are we doing
all right so eggs benedict
yes right are you making a hollandaise
yes i am when are you making it
so actually i don't have the blender and
i didn't use it properly so
you don't need a blender to make
hollandaise i know right that's what i'm
used to
okay listen you know that hollandaise
cannot break
yes if that holidays breaks your dish is
done okay okay i'm not that worried i am
very confident about the sauce i think
it will come out great
no big deal right no big deal all right
looking good
jim how you doing i'm uh the antithesis
of leslie i think
yeah i'm uh all worked up just about
done okay
is your persian spice in here yes it is
i can smell it wow so that's fantastic
um where's your eggs uh right here i did
two just in case one broke so i'm gonna
looks a little bit not so nice huh yeah
exactly so i went with two
three minutes left guys make sure those
eggs are perfect good luck
thank you everyone allow enough time for
a beautiful presentation please
leslie yes you're therapist aren't you
yes i am
tell me what's wrong with me i'm too
critical of people fix me what can i do
relax relax breathe i can't relax when
you're doing this in front of me
thank you how's your how's your dish
going my dish is gonna be great
there we go two minutes left guys two
minutes left
think about your presentation think
about everything coming together listen
you have a lot of stuff
taste it taste as you go okay yep
kyle's hollandaise i don't know if it's
gonna work he's running out of time and
he's put that hollandaise on his ex
benedict
jim's pasta is looking good that poached
egg i'm not sure about
i hope it turns out perfectly uh listen
leslie is very confident she's calm and
cool she promises she's gonna fix me
later all right everyone
clean beautiful plates things that you
would see at a restaurant please
we're in our final minute
kyle oh no i don't know if kyle's
hollandaise is working
it looks like droopy drippy raw egg to
me yeah
30 seconds just 30 seconds left folks
kyle looks pretty despondent at this
point there's still time he can he can
get it back on the thing and can't whisk
it up he just needs more whiskey i think
he's giving up i think he's just giving
up
it doesn't look that great uh i've
definitely made better holiday sauce
there's still seconds on the clock you
can still go ten
nine nine eight seven
six five four three
two one time is up away from your
workstation all right
[Applause]
welcome back to the final part of
culinary genius where it's time for
edward to judge
our finalists egg dishes so let's go
right in
i feel confident i had one dish to
execute and i believe i executed it well
i'm going up against some difficult
opponents so it'll be interesting to see
what the chef decides when i saw it all
finished
i think that i could have done better so
i tried to throw in a little asparagus
on the side
as always putting the egg on the dish i
wish it had been a bit smaller
because it would look better nice
presentation
i like your use of color the peas
everything stand out it
looks like something i want to eat let's
jump in then all right
[Applause]
i'm tasting that persian spice which is
really nice it's giving me this
explosion of aroma
the egg even though it looks a little
paltry that yolk part is perfect
i want you to taste it it needs more
salt
tell me if you agree or not
unless you like your food plant i salted
it
i salted it yeah i didn't want to over
salt it you just need that salt in and
otherwise though listen everything is
works perfectly on the plate all right
thank you
obviously your hollandaise didn't work i
have one rule in my kitchen
which is you never never ever ever give
up
okay every sauce can be rescued
no dish is ever too late to fix but
listen
i'm looking at your poached eggs which
is what this competition was about
and they look beautiful what's up with
this where'd the tips go
i cut them just to kind of hide it yeah
i would have sliced them into small
circles
and then just garnish the plate around
you know it's just it's just weird
yeah all right
the eggs are slightly overcooked but
they're nice
the asparagus is actually cooked really
well they taste delicious
and the flavor of the holiday is great
it just needed the body and the texture
you know
so if you just pulled in a little bit
more technique this would have been a
fantastic dish thank you
you call this originally a nasi goreng
just kind of like an indonesian fried
rice um
and then we got a nice big piece of fish
and then taco so
you've been pulling from a lot of
different places listen the
this sunny-side up egg is perfect
so how do you want me to do you want me
to eat it or you want to make a taco out
of it i would
probably mix in a bit of the egg into
the rice look at that
yeah and i'd try and make a little bit
of rice
a little bit of fish and make it too
soft all right
that was the idea
a little bit of egg
[Applause]
it's your own little restaurant here
there we go it's all about fun right
it's still a little bit confusing to me
yes right i mean you could have just
given me
this yes without that but the flavor of
the rice that rice is cooked perfect
fish is cooked perfect beautiful sunny
side of eggs so great job i really loved
it well done leslie all right well all
three cooks have done their very best
but now of course edward has the
tricky task of choosing a winner so
edward i think we need to take a moment
to reveal today's winner finalists
please
lift your cloches today's culinary
genius
is leslie
[Applause]
i don't know what's in that marinade but
it needs to be bottled in a sauce
put my name on the bottom
congratulations to our
culinary genius
you